welcome to this video playing Carlotto
from this is not hard to spot this is
not the Netherlands but hard to spot
what's in the middle pair of wires would
have been my guess actually this is
basically the Netherlands flag biz with
something in the middle which is hard to
figure out maybe a son how to tell it so
so little here oke for being played and
I wasted 30 seconds on the flag
discussion um yeah first things first
let's do the Sicilian okay it seems you
feel obliged to also think 30 seconds of
two again idea three sound let's be
quicker here and see maybe maybe go for
the time man or variation and some
always been a favorite of mine back from
ya when I was starting out with the with
chess I always liked this particular
line with Quincy sudden you get typical
Sicilian play but quite often um
this is this crazy line with night here
right I mean a bit should be 6 cm there
is a slight bishop b6 okay he's not
doing that that says it's very good
besides the fact that I don't know this
really this is a line but should be six
besides the fact that I don't know it
really am it it would strongly have
hinted at an engine abuser so it does
not seem to be the case one major
difference of the tomorrow compared to
two other Sicilians is that you get the
bishop out quickly here unlike in this
Craven ningun on night off where there's
also always a pawn on d6 this is not the
case here ok
mmm yeah what about the bishop to g6
this also be to hanging yeah that's
probably good anyway let's let's play it
and not to waste much time f4 em their
form
hmm yeah now queen bee to there is a 5
yeah this is this is a dangerous for
black or one night move first
yeah this is so I didn't really didn't
really appreciate them strength of this
smooth I wonder i can i can maybe play
five this is somewhat somewhat shaky
yeah it looks shaky the smoothly drive
taking here there's even night a four to
be six yeah that's not clear at all okay
what else I can play d4 maybe d flexible
d for Bishop takes Bishop a form it
taking here and there should be five
yeah okay come on this at least them
fights for the look sorry fights for the
e5 square and it's with a temple so okay
wow wow but I can just recapture right I
don't want to take on on edge to witness
this looks a bit strange but here he
really does not have a move I mean age
three looks looks totally totally insane
for the light squares I mean no this is
not really good and g3 I just take it
and this is what being made and a couple
of moves probably Bishop takes HD Queen
tales made so he needs to play this move
that I just described at ridiculous
which is not not making fun out of em
it's just it just looks so so so
horrible to to weaken in the light
squares like that yeah maybe it's really
the move that needed to be played okay
here and now that sets quite a lot look
g3 as a possibility queen bee to
this is the this is a monster on e5 sort
of I don't know it's like a tall
lighthouse in the CAF to looking at all
directions just a fantastic piece okay
but all this is nice but what I need is
I need to get something concrete going
and this is on the G file check here and
this he does not really have a great
move available I'd like to double on the
g4 maybe Bishop g7 first king e7 and
then doubling what I have is an
excellent structure and this fantastic
bishop what I don't have its development
so this is also the reason why this
position is not falling apart quickly
for white because I don't have all
pieces and play if I get the rook e8 and
into the play and get rooks connected
then it will be a very very quickly big
big problems yes but I thought queen bee
four is good
yeah that's not waste time I take this
and now it's there yeah maybe see three
years a move ready I wonder ever should
give this check to make sure that I'm
getting near the king what is this first
young come on this is a google he needs
to move the Queen now and then i can
play Queen deform maybe king e seven
root g eight yep here have all wait wait
wait wait wait wait for me wait a moment
King is 73 let's queen d 6 which is
strong okay so let's do this first let's
do this first I want to look a 2g eight
rly
and this the c5 Bishop is one of the one
of the strongest pieces i can remember
in recent game history him and on for my
own games just wow could only be better
if it would be odd there's no see porn
and on d4 so that it completely
dominates they for night yeah here can
actually win a piece but should be to
Queen deform maybe there is something
something maybe this is not really so
great because of Queen civ 5 at the end
yeah it's not not touched totally clear
okay well this I need anyway let's get
the rook here and this is g2 how does
how does he protected
yeah Bishop deform or queen deform why
can check and then queen d 4 which is a
funny funny funny fork on on the rooks
in a way okay but there is no no way to
directly win the game at least there
Bishop before probably okay it's no
reason to get particularly fancy here
yeah i still have crashed level g to
check it's a pretty pretty substantial
pin here yeah that's also brooke g1 now
this is a mate does not seem to be a
checkmate strangely enough check digest
it and now i don't see a maid or bishop
g3 as this checkmate bishop g3 King
takes Queenie one check this is a medium
check yeah this is a checkmate
check made on f 2 and H to check
white resigns yeah i mean this is this
structure I mean it's just it really
took their very quickly and this is this
is just just you cannot do that week
it's simply giving black such a big
strategical advantage just unbearable
you absolutely need to play a move like
I don't know really Queen f3 maybe or h3
h3 Bishop b5 also looks nice but it's
not comparable to what to what we got on
the board it was overwhelming yeah after
this this is just such a piece only five
unbelievable yeah and see this you can
absolutely cannot cannot withstand this
pressure either computer actually see
the first made in five if probably about
what happened in the game yeah it came
to yeah okay you could think about other
here maybe this is an interesting spot
d5 a certainty right and now this here
computer 1c5 yeah I thought about this
move it's not bad certainly not but ok
this is this is a playable option and
here this is this is basically losing
strategically it's just this piece
single piece only five is so strong the
rest of the board does not matter i get
this g file as well this is the
additional problem yeah that is this is
to be too good for black absolutely okay
i hope you enjoyed this thanks for
watching